we have six weeks to harvest a million
christmas trees
and that means you gotta move fast
as soon as harvest starts it's time to
call in the calvary
the state of oregon is the largest
supplier of christmas trees in the
country
here in oregon christmas trees outnumber
people 12 to 1.
holiday tree farms is one of the largest
christmas tree farms in the world we
have about 8 000 acres of actively
growing trees
the only thing we grow is christmas
trees
we sell a million christmas trees a year
but you got to remember we harvest them
in a very short period of time
we can cut and process a christmas tree
and have it loaded on a truck in less
than 24 hours the steps in harvesting a
christmas tree start with cutting each
tree individually with a chainsaw
slingers will pile the trees and rig
them for extraction next we bring a
helicopter and fly them into waiting
trucks
each tree is shaken bale and loaded and
then it's on its way to market
[Music]
holidays started using helicopters in
the early 1980s
they're a lot faster than doing it by
hand
a helicopter can harvest about a
thousand trees an hour
we normally run between five or six
helicopters every day sun up to sundown
we've been taking care of these trees
ever since they were very tiny seedlings
an average noble fur is about eight
years old when we harvest it and it's
six to seven feet tall
harvest is my favorite time of the year
that's when we get to see the payoff for
six seven eight years worth of work
for every tree that we harvest we plant
another tree in its place so when we
harvest a million trees we plant over a
million trees the next spring it never
stops
so what do i think of fake trees is
christmas tree farmer they're our number
one competition obviously
we real tree farmers have a saying about
fake trees nine years in the house and
nine million years in landfill they
cannot be recycled
it's christmas keep it real
you